thrilled to have here on the program in
the flesh is a pro football hall of
famer barry sanders courtesy of rocket
mortgage super bowl squares sweepstakes
how are you sir good to see you very
well very well okay now great to be here
man how are you i'm better for seeing
you now we frequently get people just
calling and they're hanging up right
right what just happened right so
someone someone called in and said that
he had a friend in the mid 90s
height
of barry sanders in detroit yes and said
that barry would go to oakland
university and play pick up basketball
or shoot around is this true
no i was playing man i wasn't just
shooting around i was playing i mean you
know i'm a player man so this guy this
guy's story he says that a friend of his
you asked him to run five like join his
team and his friend said no i got my
five like denied you
the chance to play in the game
and then you went off and shot around by
yourself i'm not sure about that part
rich because they i always got picked to
play rich i always got picked to play so
i don't know about that source
somebody's calling and saying i didn't i
refused to play
i had a friend of his
got a friend of his and they they made
fun of this guy forever for like what do
you mean you didn't pick up barry
sanders on your squad but i did play a
lot of basketball at oakland university
um you know it was my way just like
really like on off day you know that was
kind of my workout you know i'd go play
basketball and obviously the coaches
weren't supposed to know about this
that's about sex
i was about to say
what's better i was careful though i was
very careful out there well plus you
know
there's
no one could probably contact you on the
court anyway
because that's you that you couldn't be
conscious of my moves right on the
basketball that's right
nobody could even hit you with an elbow
because you're just making moves what
was what's your what's the barry sanders
basketball game look like what's that
look like the skeleton report version
what is it i mean i thought i was a
decent outside shooter you know decent
decent hops okay you know i was uh back
then i could i could probably throw it
down
um you know i wasn't i was involved in a
few dunk contests you know back back in
those days but you could dunk um in
basketball yeah on a 10-foot goal not
just yeah but of course yeah right yeah
like an actual regulation rim
right i just want to be clear yeah
but are you in traffic or you needed to
have a fast break to dunk like could you
could you dunk in traffic back then yeah
i could i i probably didn't really need
much of a run to start i mean as if
you're talking about a young barry
sanders that's what we're talking about
no i i can't imagine what a [ __ ] his
friend that's what i'm saying
hey hey i'm barry sanders can i run five
with you no we got our team
somebody's getting kicked off the team
obviously he wasn't trying to
win the game
back here on the rich eisen show with
our terrestrial radio outfit joining us
on peacock and sirius xm the rich eisen
show netsuite by oracle is a sponsor of
the rich eisen show ready to upgrade go
to netsuite.com
rich barry sanders pro football hall of
famer here on the program again courtesy
of the rocket mortgage super bowl
squares sweepstakes how are you sir good
to see you once again you're good so
good to be here man absolutely thanks
for being here what do you think of
matthew stafford being in this super
bowl
barry sanders what do you think of that
oh i mean i think it's great and i know
as a lot of lions fans um you know
there's mixed feelings right because a
lot a lot of us
um you know have a bitter taste in my
mouth just having him all those years
um and not being able to to have more
success you know but yes but for me you
know to see him in a situation where
um he's really just thrived and he's
really answered a lot of questions about
okay you know can this guy do this can
he do that um you know it's great to see
and
and um you know you couldn't you
couldn't hope for a better situation for
him you know so i love it um i think i
think he's as motivated and has as much
to prove as anybody in this game
um you know and there's probably a few
more on this team like odell beckham you
know i'm sure you're sure he feels like
he has something to prove as well as i'm
sure you know all the rams do but those
guys in particular and especially
matthew but following him all those
years um in detroit and hearing all
those you know the questions and doubts
as to what what he can and can't do so
i'm happy with how things have turned
out for him this year yeah and and
especially since you you know he's been
open about it and the stories have been
written about it
the emotional decision
to sit there with his wife and say
i think i'm going to go into ownership
and i'm gonna ask out i think we should
ask out or
let's come together and decide together
as a family that we're gonna we're gonna
ask out it's not an easy thing i mean
fans are like of course he's gonna leave
the lines be very honest you know you
retired megatron retired and it's just a
sense of like of course you can there it
was a very difficult decision for him
and it's wound up with him going to a
spot that's put him in the super bowl or
he's helped lead them to a super bowl
it's kind of amazing no no it really is
and he he's done everything um the right
way and and um
you know i'm sure i wonder you know how
many times had he thought about that you
know as he got later on in his career
how many times had he thought about
having that conversation you know and
and uh for him
um you know he he faced it um you know
and and did what he thought was best for
him and his family
and yeah i just i love seeing the way
that things have worked out for him
because obviously
you know you get a chance to see okay
the guy um
you know for all those years putting up
all those numbers um
you know and and uh
and not able to really
you know see the fruits of that labor um
and see that the results that you would
normally see of a guy with those sort of
numbers so yes it's it's good as a fan
just seeing him put himself in that
position did you ever think of having
that conversation
say i want out as opposed to retiring
did you ever think about that barry
i never really did i mean i think for me
i was i was just done i felt like i was
done playing um it was just uh just that
drive and motivation to continue to play
um
you know in in the right perfect
circumstance with i don't know what that
would have been back then
um i don't know if you know
if faced with those options but for me
then i was pretty much done yo because i
mean with stafford it was just like i i
can still play i think i want out i want
a different spot and he asked for it do
you think the answer would have been the
same from management back in the day if
you had come
to the same conclusion
and gone in that direction
probably not i think it was a different
game back then i think uh you know i
think old man ford is probably different
than you know the mom or the daughter of
ford but
to say the least
you know so but certainly you know
certainly just the way that situations
like that would have been handled um no
i don't i i mean i can only guess
um but uh it probably would have been a
different answer calvin johnson was on
the show friday barry sanders and i
asked him
do you feel
that matthew stafford in a way if not
flat out winning the super bowl he's
kind of winning it for you and your
teammates that played with him and
thought you could have done it
and his answer was damn right
like i think he cut me off right in the
middle of like he knew where i was going
with the oh yeah with the with the
question do you
would you maybe even feel that way being
from even a different generation of like
what would i like take some credit for
it no no not take no way right just
right you'll feel a part of it part of
it you feel like some ownership like
yeah he
did it
you know albeit clearly obviously
somewhere else but he is somebody who is
grown up in the same system yeah in the
same organization that you helped also
continue to well put back on the map in
a way
so what about you about that yeah i
would feel
um
a part of it in some way yes i mean he
was he was with the lions last year last
season so so yes i would feel that and
even like as a player
when some of my former teammates had
gone on like lomas brown
went on to play in the super bowl and
won one with the bucks i i felt very
proud and there was a part of me that
that felt
um
that i had you know some small part or
played some small part in it because we
were such good buddies
um you know and we played so many years
together um you know so absolutely i i
definitely feel sort of a connection to
it and and um
certainly
you know
different than had i not played with the
guy you know or he not being with our
franchise yes i feel like there's a
connection barry sanders here on the
rich eisen show okay so um how do you
see the game playing what's your two
cents on how it all shakes out on sunday
here barry
well i mean i i love um
i love the match up and and um
you look at what the bengals have have
been able to accomplish this season
obviously there's still more to do for
them
but
you look at them knocking off the titans
uh the chiefs
no one expected them to be here
[Music]
you know you look at how their culture
has changed over the last few years
um you know they've uh
they
earned a right to be here you know and
and um if i had to choose one i would
probably say i would probably say the
rams just because i think um
you know i think they're a stronger team
uh both sides of the ball um you look
you look at their roster and you know
the
the um guys like von miller and aaron
donald and jalen ramsey and matthew
stafford cooper cup odell i mean that is
a very strong roster to be able to put
together yes um
you know to all play on the same team
so that's so if i had to choose one yes
i would probably lean toward the rams
but all the games in the playoffs have
been closed well i mean over time i mean
you know so you can definitely expect a
nail biter and and i'm sure the bengals
feel like
feel like they're the underdog and um
have a lot to have a lot to prove and in
this in this day and age in this league
i mean anything can happen who was the
aaron donald of your time barry sanders
who was that guy that was ready white
probably reggie white yeah he was he was
unblockable
um you know he first started off with
the eagles obviously and they had a
fantastic defense
um
you know uh coached by buddy ryan you
know and the defensive wizard that
bloody ryan was and then obviously
reggie left there and came to the
packers
and played and teamed up with with brett
favre and and uh they played in two
consecutive super bowls and and yeah
yeah reggie reggie um the hall of fame
defensive end yeah he was you know he
gave us fits man did he ever get you
i'm sure he did
no i mean
i would imagine like
i tried to stay away from him you know i
did my best to stay away from him but
eventually yeah no eventually reggie's
going to get
you didn't have you don't have an i
juked reggie white story you don't have
that sort of story
barry
i mean i think i think there's
some footage somewhere out there where
that may have happened okay yeah i mean
you know we were two great players going
at each other he he won this year i you
know i i
went here and there you're being very
modest do you remember every single
person you juked barry
no okay how about your best do you like
a top five you know like if you if
you've pressured you could list it or
number one your number one juke
guy again like again i don't
i mean to put you in a situation where
you're flexing and you normally don't
that's not your default but i'd like to
know
i
[Laughter]
yes that's correct
i think um
the one they show
against the the patriots
uh playing in the silver dome
is is a good one where the guy is kind
of spinning around yeah he's spinning
around yeah that i i like that one did
you see that in real time i just spun
somebody around as you're going down the
field
is it did you see that in real life yeah
and i was i was probably i probably had
a smile on my face as i was running
i love that
yeah
running down the field yes barry who
remembers shaking he shook everyone who
stepped on the field with him so name
did anybody ever come up to you and just
angry at you
and let you know
[Laughter]
did you did that ever happen in a game
anger yes anger was expressed in many
games yes in your direction yes in my
direction and that did absolutely did
that make you laugh or feed your fire
which one was that no i loved it no i
loved it i mean you know we're all big
boys it's a part of the game um i take
it as a sign of respect
barry sanders here on the rich eyes okay
rocket mortgage super bowl squares
sweepstakes
half million bucks for somebody right
potentially george towards their dream
home correct yes yes i mean rocket
mortgage giving fans a chance to win a
lot of cash during super bowl and so
they're back um
you know with a game of squares uh best
game of squares big biggest and best
game of squares and so basically every
time the score changes in the game
rocket mortgage will give away 50 000 to
a fan
and then as you mentioned um
you know twice at halftime and at end of
the game they'll give away half a
million dollars
to
fans and they and they've given away
like over three million dollars over the
last uh few years for super bowl and 29
winners for 3.3 million bucks in the
last two years so go to rocketmore
squares.com if you want to find out more
about it um the entry window closes this
friday midnight
um it's free to play uh so so uh
you know a great great chance for fans
win a lot of cash fantastic yeah
rocketmortgagesquares.com it's funny my
kids saw one of these uh grids you know
on a wall at somebody's place
they're like dad what is this thing and
i actually
explained to them
these numbers at the top are going to
get filled in these numbers on the side
are going to get filled in and if
you have that square you get a and just
i found it interesting that i was
explaining this to a kid for
[Laughter]
you know i
mean rocketmortgagesquares.com
uh it's the rocket mortgage super bowl
squares sweepstakes again free to enter
giving away more than a million dollars
in cash prizes and entries are open
through this friday february 11. you're
the man barry sanders thanks for coming
in always great appreciate it man always
great to see you man thanks for having
me at barry sanders on twitter and
instagram right here on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here